like all of Guillermo del Toro's films
Pinocchio is complex deeply
contemplative and far more than it seems
here's what this master of the Macabre
has to say about the classic tale
spoilers ahead the historical setting of
Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio
immediately lets you know that the film
will have a more serious Focus than past
versions of the story the beginning of
the movie takes place during World War
One and as warplanes are making their
way back to base they drop bombs just to
lighten their load one of those bombs
lands on Geppetto's church and kills his
son Carlo from there the film's anti-war
message becomes even more explicit by
the time Geppetto creates Pinocchio many
years have passed World War one has come
to a close but Benito Mussolini has come
to power in Italy and fascists dominate
almost every aspect of daily life in
Geppetto's town and the surrounding
areas Geppetto like many of the other
Italian citizens does his best to play
along with what the fascists want to
avoid any violence at their hands
Pinocchio Isn't So agreeable he's a
rambunctious young boy who likes to do
things his way just by being himself
Pinocchio shines a light on just how
wrong the fascist belief system is the
primary antagonist of the film The
Carnival owner count Volpe and the
government representative POTUS ta are
both fascists who want to crush
Pinocchio's spirit for the glory of the
Fatherland it's Pinocchio's
individualist streak unlimited optimism
and empathy for other people that
ultimately allow him to Prevail over his
foes
in all its different forms Pinocchio's
story is partly a coming-of-age tale
about a boy learning how to be good and
take responsibility for his actions and
most versions of the tale like Disney's
classic rendition from the 1940s
learning to be good is synonymous with
learning to obey the people who are
supposed to be in charge Pinocchio
usually learns that if he follows what
the adults in his life tell him then
things will generally work out for him
in Guillermo del Toro's version of the
story however most of the adults in
Pinocchio's life are fascists espousing
terrible rules and life philosophies
that only serve to devalue other people
look at my boy Candlewick yes yeah model
fascist youth proud Brave virile
Geppetto might not truly be a fascist
himself but even Pinocchio's father
can't serve as a great example for the
young boy because he's willing to go
along with what the fascists want unlike
past versions of the story Pinocchio in
this film doesn't need to learn how to
obey his disobedience is what sets him
apart from the other people in his life
and it's what makes him a hero for Del
Toro Pinocchio's disobedience in the
film is the whole point speaking with
the Washington Post he said Disobedience
now is more urgent than ever Pinocchio's
real journey through the movie is
learning how to use that Disobedience to
help others like when he breaks death's
rules and hourglass to save Geppetto's
life
Pinocchio doesn't learn how to be
obedient in the film but he does learn
how to be good at the beginning of the
movie Pinocchio breaks rules to get what
he wants he leaves Geppetto's house to
follow his father to church he skips out
on going to school because he wants to
drink hot chocolate at the carnival by
the end of the movie he's breaking rules
to save lives what changed Pinocchio's
Journey away from home takes him through
plenty of hardships but two moments in
particular demonstrate how Pinocchio's
experiences cause him to change his
attitude in life first Pinocchio sees
count Volpe beating and berating
spazatura he immediately steps in to
defend the monkey and when that doesn't
work the two of them conspire to
sabotage the Count's performance for
Mussolini later Pinocchio is taken to a
training camp for fascist soldiers there
he comes to understand that his old
bully Candlewick was just being cruel
because that's what his father podesta
taught him to do Pinocchio and
Candlewick become friends and rebel
against podestaad's rules throughout the
film Pinocchio suffers but he also
Witnesses the suffering of others at the
hands of the people in charge all of
that convinces him to change the way he
goes about disobeying and transforms him
into a true hero
Pinocchio isn't the only one who changes
over the course of the film he also
transforms the people who are closest to
him Geppetto goes through the biggest
change but Sebastian's transformation
has the biggest effect on the film's
plot after Geppetto loses his son Carlo
all his joy for Life vanishes his work
slows down to the point that even when
his Town's Church gets rebuilt he never
finishes his new crucifix carving
because he spends the majority of his
time drinking the war ends in 1918
Benito Mussolini Rises to power in Italy
in 1922 and Geppetto remains lost the
Wood Sprite gives Pinocchio life so he
can bring joy back into Geppetto's life
the two of them get off to a rough start
but by the end of the movie Geppetto has
found love and motivation all over again
he's willing to risk being eaten by a
monstrous sea creature just to see
Pinocchio again Sebastian begins as a
self-centered writer whose main interest
in Pinocchio is that he already has a
home set up inside the wood of the
puppet's body the Wood Sprite promises
Sebastian one wish if he teaches
Pinocchio to be good but things work out
in the opposite direction Sebastian
tries giving Pinocchio a lesson or two
but by spending time with the boy
Sebastian himself learns to be more
selfless he uses his wish not for fame
but to bring Pinocchio back to life well
gosh darn it
I wish him back to life
there's another character in the movie
who goes through a drastic change thanks
to Pinocchio and his transformation
mirrors Pinocchio's growth Candlewick is
the son of podesta a war obsessed
fascist government official who lives in
Pinocchio's town when the boys first
meet Candlewick takes a cue from his
father and acts like a bully toward
Pinocchio going so far that he convinces
Pinocchio to stick his wooden legs in a
fire all that changes in the film's
Final Act podesta's ships Candlewick off
to a special military training camp for
young boys and eventually Pinocchio
finds himself there as well bodista is
obsessed with the idea of using
Pinocchio as an immortal Soldier but
neither of the children is genuinely
interested in fighting a war at the
training camp Candlewick confesses to
Pinocchio that he just wants to make his
father proud of him and Pinocchio
Comforts him by telling him all fathers
love their sons but fathers are still
people and don't always behave the way
they should in a training exercise
Pinocchio and Candlewick come to a tie
and podesta orders his son to shoot his
new friend Candlewick refuses finally
telling his father that he doesn't need
his approval he and Pinocchio rebel
against the Camp's leadership just as
bombs Begin to Fall
Guillermo del Toro spends some time
musing on mortality in Pinocchio shortly
after count volt Bay's Carnival is
introduced the count and Geppetto get
into a fight over Pinocchio that ends
when the puppet gets hit by podista's
car to the humans it appears as though
Pinocchio died but he wakes up in a
version of the afterlife populated by
skeletal rabbits and a sphinx-like
creature called Death who says that the
Wood Sprite is her sister death tells
Pinocchio that the Wood Sprite brought
him to life because she doesn't care
about following rules then death
explains the rules of Pinocchio's new
almost afterlife every time he dies
he'll arrive in her world and have to
wait for larger and larger hourglasses
to run through their sand before he gets
sent back to the world of the living
near the end of the movie Pinocchio dies
while Geppetto is drowning and he breaks
The Hourglass to get back more quickly
even though it means he'll become truly
mortal Pinocchio dies one final time in
his efforts to save Geppetto but thanks
to Sebastian's wish and the wood Sprites
magic he gets resurrected and has the
chance to live out his life with his
family death may have warned Pinocchio
that by breaking The Hourglass he'd gain
mortality and become a real boy but she
also knew that her sister would
intervene death's warning was more about
testing Pinocchio's character than it
was about limiting his lifespan
when Sebastian enters the film he begins
narrating different events he explains
that when he first met Pinocchio he was
a writer working on a book about his
life and he tells the story of how he
first got involved with Geppetto his
puppet and the Wood Sprite at the end of
the film Sebastian talks about
Pinocchio's long life with Geppetto and
spasitura who both eventually die as
Pinocchio goes on agelessly in some
instances of Sebastian's narration the
camera shows him writing as he's
speaking which make it all the more
surprising when Sebastian begins to
narrate over his own death just after
seeing that Sebastian like the others
died we catch up with him in the
afterlife playing cards with the
skeletal rabbits who work for Death the
transition makes for a quick twist it
reveals that all this time Sebastian
wasn't narrating from some Grand book
that he wrote about his adventures he
gave up that dream to save Pinocchio's
life instead Sebastian has been telling
his life story to the disinterested
rabbits over a few hands of poker the
Darkly humorous turn in the story is
emblematic of what sets Guillermo del
Toro's Pinocchio apart from other takes
on the story
sadly Pinocchio outlives Geppetto
spasitura and Sebastian he's not a human
being and he never ages even as the
people around him do the tragic part of
his existence is something that death
warns him about when he first visits her
domain initially Pinocchio is thrilled
at the prospect of being Immortal but
death tells him that immortality is more
of a curse than a blessing life can
bring great suffering
and eternal life can bring
Eternal suffering when Pinocchio decides
to break death's hourglass so he has
enough time to save Geppetto from
drowning in the sea she tells him that
not following her rules will make him
mortal again does the wood sprite's
final Spell fulfilling Sebastian's wish
undo Pinocchio's Newfound mortality yes
and no Pinocchio is still on his last
life like death told him he would be the
Wood Sprite gives him one more chance at
that life but she doesn't make Pinocchio
truly Immortal again the way he was
before breaking The Hourglass that said
Pinocchio is still a wooden puppet so he
isn't likely to die from old age anytime
soon at the end of the film Sebastian
says that he imagines Pinocchio didn't
live forever but his friend still gets
to have an extraordinarily long life
compared to normal humans
and the film death claims that
Pinocchio's realness is tied to his
mortality she says that human life is
unique because it is short but even
though Pinocchio gets to live for a very
long time he's still gone through the
transformation of becoming a real boy by
the end of the film in more traditional
versions of Pinocchio's story like
Disney's classic film his journey ends
when he gets magically transformed into
a physical human being that was never
going to be the case in Guillermo del
Toro's version speaking with Vanity Fair
Del Toro revealed to me it's essential
to counter the idea that you have to
change into a flesh and blood child to
be a real human all you need to be human
is to really behave like one you know
Pinocchio's transformation from an
inhuman puppet to a real boy was a slow
process that began when he first met
Geppetto at the beginning of the film in
a way every interaction he had with the
people he met further pushed him toward
Humanity but it was the moment that
Pinocchio smashed death's hourglass that
sealed his Fate by being so full of love
that he was willing to sacrifice his own
life Pinocchio truly embodied what it
means to be human despite her massive
impact on everything that happens to
Geppetto Sebastian and Pinocchio the
movie doesn't reveal all that much about
the Wood Sprite she first appears as a
collection of glowing orbs that
seemingly take interest in Geppetto's
suffering as he chops down a tree while
mourning the death of his son Carlo in
his narration Sebastian admits that he
knows very little about what the orbs
are or why they're suddenly flocking to
Geppetto's side later when Pinocchio
visits the afterlife for the first time
death tells him that the Wood Sprite is
her sister the two of them share a
resemblance with large wings that appear
to have eyeballs sticking out all over
them but death gets more screen time and
has much more to say than her sister in
her final appearance in the film The
Wood Sprite Grand Sebastian his wish and
returns Pinocchio to life it seems like
she might have known that things would
work out this way all along to save you
he became a real boy
and real boys
don't come back however it's unclear how
much she and her sister communicated and
planned during the events of the film
ultimately the Wood Sprite has little to
say or reveal she's simply a mysterious
force of nature that will never be fully
understood
[Music]